l'idée c'est qu'on fasse une arrivée
propre parce que vous êtes une sorte de
metteur en scène vous êtes une sorte de
chef d'orchestre vous êtes sous
l'autorité du chef de cabinet le rôle du
chef de cabinet et de la chefferie de
cabinet il est très clair c'est
l'organisation générale la coordination
générale il est le chef d'orchestre des
déplacements et des événements du palais
et il est également le metteur en scène
si je peux me permettre de parler ainsi
et pour être prêt pondre manière très
claire j'avais quatre missions à
l'elysée ma première mission était
l'organisation des déplacements
nationaux dans le cadre de ce que je
viens de vous expliquer la force que
vous en aviez déjà connaissance il est l
organisation d événements au palais dans
le cadre de ce que je viens de vous
expliquer la également dont vous avez
connaissance il était le cadre
l'organisation et je vais employer le
terme parce que ce qu'on appelle les
déplacements privés du président de la
république je pourrais m'en expliquer si
vous avez des questions là-dessus et il
était dans une tasse dans une tâche par
donc on l'a appelée coordination des
services de sécurité la coordination des
services de sécurité je pense vous avoir
expliqué le par mon parcours ça que j'ai
une petite connaissance du domaine de la
sécurité il consistait pas à être le
chef de la sécurité de l'elysée il
consistait à conduire un certain nombre
de réunions de réflexion souvent si vous
prenez le colonel lavergne qui est
maintenant général qui a besoin de 12
voitures supplémentaires par exemple
pour son parc automobile
s'il n'a pas un appui politique si le
cabinet n'aide pas c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne c'est le cabinet ne l'aide
pas il pourra aller demander 12 voitures
au ministère de l'intérieur
il sera tout seul face au ministère de
l'intérieur et c'est souvent ce qui se
passe donc par exemple j'avais en charge
le renouvellement du parc automobile de
l'elysée parce qu'à un moment vous êtes
vous fait des réunions à un autre niveau
que deux chefs de service administration
centrale vous faites une réunion un
niveau cabinet c'est à dire le cabinet
du président de la république saisi le
cabinet du ministre l'intérieur parce
qu'il a besoin de moyens supplémentaires
voilà c'était c'était pas une pour pour
répondre très précisément
ce n'était pas une fonction
opérationnelle de sécurité c'était une
fonction administrative